praktisch jeder hat sein eigenes
Kartoffelsalat Rezept aber bei den
wenigsten ist die Geheimzutat Zucker und
jetzt kommt ganz viel süße Sebastian
zeigt was noch alles in den
industriekartoffelsalaten steckt und sie
wochenlang frisch
hält ich mein es sind Kartoffeln drinne
das kann ich ihn schon mal
verraten und sogar
71%. Zwiebeln Rapsöl Wasser Zucker
brandweinessig 75% Kartoffeln Rapsöl und
dann gleich brandweinessig hier auch
wieder brandweinessig also Kartoffel
Wasser Rapsöl Zucker und dann
brandweinessig und fast bei allen gleich
Säure Säure Säure ein steht fest die
fertigen Produkte sind extrem sauer mit
Zucker wird aufgepuffert geschmacklich
aber auch für die Konservierung und wie
das ganze funktioniert und wie man so
ein Kartoffelsalat macht genau das zeige
ich ihn
jetzt in einem industriellen
Kartoffelsalat stecken einige
ungewöhnliche Inhaltsstoffe der Salat
soll im Kühlregal auch nach zi Wochen
noch genießbar sein dafür werden die
frischen Zutaten behandelt auch Gurken
und
[Musik]
Zwiebeln normalerweise würde man jetzt
alles zusammen kippen ein bisschen Essig
drauf ein bisschen Öl drauf lecker
abschmecken fertig aber nicht so bei
industriell hergestellten
Kartoffelsalat Gurken und Zwiebeln
verlieren im Salat schnell ih knackige
Konsistenz auf ihnen können sich
Bakterien ausbreiten das will Sebastian
lege verhindern er legt das Gemüse ein
in einer Mischung aus mehreren
natürlichen Konservierungsstoffen zübeln
sind drin so dann erstmal der
Essig dann Wasser die Säure im Essig
verhindert dass sich unerwünschte
Mikroorganismen bilden seit
Jahrhunderten gilt Essig als natürlicher
Konservierungsstoff
als nächstes gibt Sebastian legel Zucker
dazu Zucker sorgt auch dafür dass man
noch mehr Essig rein machen kann für
noch längere Haltbarkeit weil umso mehr
Zucker umso weniger schmeckt man den
Essig Salz auch natürlich für die
haltbmachung alles verschließen und
schön
durchschütteln eingelegt sind die
Zwiebeln mehrere Monate haltbar im Salat
bleiben sie lange frisch und
knackig sind fertig dann legen wir mal
los mit den Kartoffeln die sind schon
vorgekocht und kommen in Sebastian leges
Mischer dafür hat er ein Bierfass
umfunktioniert Grundlage der Salatsoße
ist Wasser Salz sorgt für
Geschmack
Säureregulatoren halten die Säure
konstant als Bindemittel folgen
guernmehl und modifizierte
Stärke
manimweiene Mittel damit die
flieeigenschaft genauso ist als hätte
man diesen Kartoffelsalat mit Brühe ein
bisschen länger gerührt wo natürliche
Stärke
entsteht und jetzt kommt ganz viel süße
weil es kommt ja auch ganz viel Säure
rein und richtig lange Haltbarkeit
Zucker ist der absolute Hero wenn es
darum geht Produkte in ihrer
Langlebigkeit auf eine ganz weite Reise
zu schicken Zucker konserviert und
gleicht die Essigsäure geschmacklich
wieder aus kaum ein fertiger
Kartoffelsalat kommt ohne
aus eine Stichprobe zeigt Werte mit bis
zu 8 g Zucker pro 100 g noch süßer sind
krautsalate mit bis zu 14 g eine echt
süße
Angelegenheit ach wie Rom frische
Kräuter keine Sorge das sind
tiefgelkräuter sind einfach nur ein paar
Farbtupfer Gurken fehlen natürlich so
die sind auch
schön süß
sauer ohne Gürkchen kein Kartoffelsalat
unsere vorgesäuerten
Zwiebeln gieen wir jetzt ab Gurken und
Zwiebeln sind bereits mit Essig Zucker
und Salz behandelt und bleiben so länger
frisch eine extra Portion Essig macht
den ganzen Salat endgültig
haltbar ich habe alles drin fehlt nur
noch
brandweinessig ja nich hier Aceto
Balsamico Obstessig oder feiner Essig
distillliert aus so einer schönen Blase
nein ganz klassischer
brandweinessig der auch in der Industrie
überall verarbeitet wird ich glaub ich
kenne da eine Adresse ich frag da
einfach mal nach der Basis Stoff für
Essig ist Alkohol weinessige entstehen
aus Weiß oder Rotwein obstessige aus der
meische von Äpfeln oder Birnen für
brandweinessig wird billiger
hochprozentiger Alkohol eingesetzt
hergestellt aus Kartoffeln Getreide oder
Zuckerrohr mit einem Preis von weniger
als 1 € pro Liter ist brandweinessig die
günstigste
[Musik]
essigsorte
in badenwürtenberg die Firma
Hengstenberg produziert seit fast 150
Jahren Essig für die Herstellung von
brandweinessig liefert ein Tanklastzug
96%zentigigen Alkohol an über ein rystem
gelangt der in die
Fabrik man riecht es schon man
rie in
dengenanntener wir brandweinessig
hergestellt wir machen hier mit den zwei
Fermentern ca 12 Millionen lit pro Jahr
pro Jahr ja genau 12 Millionen Liter
Brandwein Essig pro Jahr in Deutschland
ist ganz schön
[Gelächter]
sauer in jedem Fermenter ist bereits
etwas Essig vorhanden darin leben
Trillionen von Essigsäure Bakterien und
warten auf neue Nahrung Alkohol der wird
mit Wasser verdünnt und gelang über das
Rohrsystem in den Fermenter dann strömt
Sauerstoff dazu die Bakterien wandeln
den Alkohol in Essig
um nach dre Tagen wird der Essig
abgepumpt ein Drittel bleibt zurück für
die weitere
Produktion und der heutige Prozess ist
ein ganz natürlichen Prozess wie man
daheim in der Küche auch machen kann
also man könnte jetzt Rotwein in
essigschüssel reinleren und die lassen
wir einfach stehen wird mit der Zeit
Essig drauf was ander das machen wir
hier eigentlich nicht das Endprodukt aus
dem Fermenter ist brandweinessig mit 21%
essigsäureanteil viel zu aggressiv um
genießbar zu sein er eignet sich eher
als
Reinigungsmittel das knallt aber mal
ganz schön in der Nase
da ist aber atemwegsfrei danach oder mit
Wasser verdünnt hat der Essig noch 5%
Säure und kann als Speiseessig in den
Verkauf gehen
[Musik]
genau den brauche ich für meinen
Kartoffelsalat frischer geht's nicht
perfekt den nehme ich mit in meine
Werkstatt und mach den Kartoffelsalat
fertig da bin ich wieder frischer
brandweinessig und den brauchen wir ganz
dringend in unserem Kartoffelsalat
ansonsten 2 D Tage länger wäre ja nicht
haltbar so gehen wir hier rein
[Musik]
so bearbeitet ist der Kartoffelsalat im
Kühlregal mindestens zi Wochen lang
frisch J das sieht super aus
perfekt schön cremig der jetzt ist wie
der da reinschlotzt ist das schön
genügend Soße da rein so wir sind ja
nicht so
geizig hier ist mein fertiger
Kartoffelsalat der richtig lange haltbar
ist durch viel Brandwein Essig und
Zucker nicht nur bei fertig Salaten der
Essig Trick kommt in der gesamten
Lebensmittelindustrie zum
Einsatz all diese Produkte enthalten
brandweinessig ich bin wirklich
beeindruckt
bigoreng brandweinessig paia
brandweinessig jetzt
kommt
Brot ja Sandwich Baguette enthält
brandweinessig Currywurst ist klar wegen
dem Ketchup aber hätten Sie gedacht dass
in vegetarischen petties brandweinessig
steckt konservierende säurungsmittel
sind gesundheitlich zwar unbedenklich
problematisch ist dagegen der
Zusammenhang mit Zucker Lebensmittel die
mit bestimmten Säuren gewürzt sind mit
Essigsäure mit Zitronensäure
die werden meistens geschmacklich mit
einer großen Menge Zucker ausgeglichen
dem Zucker rechnet man in diesen
Produkten nicht unbedingt und trotzdem
ist er enthalten das heißt in die
Kalorienbilanz schlägt D mit rein und
wer langfristig solche Produkte in
größeren Mengen verzehrt der wird seine
Folgen durch den Zucker
haben eins ist klar wo Essig enthalten
ist da ist auch gleich der Zucker um die
Ecke und davon nicht zu wenig deswegen
immer nur in Maßen guten Appetit